[Music]  you're playing the genie in Aladdin for  me is a privilege and an honor that's  why I wanted to do it right I just went  all in on the genie life I was just so  excited to see him play such an iconic  character but he took the Genie stuff  pretty seriously always pretending he  was in a lamp  it was weird  will is magical very magical exactly  that's what I'm talking about do it  again that's not too tricky  oh goodness where do I start mr. Will  Smith he is a true actor very method he  poured his heart and soul into this oh  gosh wish it was lunch already your wish  is my command  Oh what have you honest it did get a  little weird once he studied grunts and  everyone's wishes when I commit I commit  [Music]  what I do  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]